good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
and
ha
bee
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend friday friday getting
down on
friday oh my god this might be the best
day of my life let me tell you why
please do
of course as most things the answer is
layered one it's friday of course two
not only is theo here he's sitting with
me and he got such a fresh haircut
yesterday due to you know unforeseen
circumstances it has been about two
months since he had gotten a haircut um
he is looking fresh feeling good sitting
next to his mummy
three
i climbed a mountain last night
i accomplished something that i was
dreading for literally two years i had
my first little test run show at city
winery with my amazing patreon family
and it was a smash like i watched a
video i recorded this morning
and i'm really proud of myself like i
definitely have work to do things i want
to you know change shift add but i did
it and that's the hardest part you did
the damn thing four
it's about to be the weekend and k is
here k is in town and i don't know if
i've ever felt this positive
ever in my life and might i give you a
five sure you're wearing fendi skims and
i'm so [ __ ] jealous because mine has
not arrived yet and
and i this is going to hurt some people
like it hurt me but one of my order
items was refunded i guess they oversold
it and i'm not getting what i ordered
even though like i set an alarm i
stopped john
i secured the bag why me why why
i trying not to take it personally or be
upset because like these things do
happen and like as someone we run a
merch business like things happen so
it's terrible like when you're that in
demand yeah no so i'm not like taking it
out on fendi or skims or kim or anyone
just like
what about me
yeah no i feel that 100 i'm really sorry
so jealous of your look the sweater
looks amazing thank you it's such an
interesting material so it's it's like
thick it's thick but it's so stretchy
like i love it and when i was on the
website i was so for clamped like i
didn't know what size to get and the
sizing was european and like i knew it
was gonna run out so i was like i'm not
going to look at a size chart and i just
like press something random you know the
bigger the better and it definitely is
like two sizes too big but i'm kind of
into that look yeah i'm so pleased with
my purchase and i really feel like if i
take really good care of it and wear it
like as much as i want in like a year
from now the secondary market could be
quaking with the sweater yeah no the
sweater is really cute i'm feeling like
inspired to make an investment in a
sweater is it still available
i think so i had gone to the store they
were still there it reminds me of that
balenciaga cardigan that everyone's been
wearing that like i've been wanting to
get but it's so expensive and then i
just like got this one
for kim of course and this one has like
snap buttons
it's really cool okay and just like you
know what i'm gonna give my money to the
brand that's size inclusive you know
like in valencia i'd probably have to
get the biggest size and i could be like
hugging my hips in the back and this one
like i'm so tiny yeah i'm swimming in
the sweater swimming and that's why we
respect kim for literally making like an
extra extra extra large on vendi which
is like never happened in the history of
fashion yeah well some thing that's new
with me is i did my hair differently too
you know i tell you i can it's it's like
haley bieber's sitting across from you
yeah it's very kendall jenner yeah no
kendall pregnant kendall jenner is in
the building
but what do you think love it i mean
it's so brave i would never wear my hair
like that but you have a skinny face so
like not you can use it you can do
things like that i just like wanted to
switch it up and i'm on my last hair day
before a wash that hair
is like
emblematic of like skinny privilege
you know yes nobody can wear their hair
like that unless you have like no fat on
your face yeah yeah no the part and the
bun the parts
i need like it's my first time doing it
i like it a lot and i don't have any
[ __ ] ponytails because bruno eats
them all and i'm on my last one and it's
already stretched because sometimes he
gets to it when i'm in the shower and so
like this is me working with like a
shitty ponytail no if i only had one um
piece of recommendation for the next
time
make your part like really sickening and
tight and middle like your part's not
visible enough like people are always
showing their part like that's the
coolest part okay the coolest part is
the part okay thank you for your
feedback but it looks great i really
like it thank you so much it's crazy to
try new things but there's nothing like
a friday when kay's in town after your
sister's accomplished her goal to try a
new hairstyle that's exactly how i was
feeling when i woke up this morning so
was i so let's talk about you
accomplishing your goal because i know
that there's so much that you know it's
been
all encompassing for you yes so i did my
show last night it was an out of body
experience like i was so unbelievably
nervous but the crowd was just like so
toasty that i actually was not nervous
at all once i got on stage it was just
the before
um and i had never tested out the
material on anyone besides like friends
and family like via facetime which is
just not the same
and it was so great i mean i definitely
want to make the show longer that's what
here's some things i picked up last
night i want to make the show longer
really want to like expand on some jokes
like i there were two parts in the show
that i think people loved the most and i
should i think i should make them bigger
you can dive deeper more physical longer
like i think i can do more
um
but all in all it was so fun and it was
so good and actually after the show i
was feeling really down but that's
always what i do because i don't
remember
if i hear people laugh like i don't
acknowledge it and then when i get off
stage i'm like nobody laughed and i was
feeling really like disappointed in
myself that like i knew i could do
better and i was like really i was like
up all night but then i had someone come
film it because i like to watch my shows
and this morning i got the tape and i
watched it before i came here and
i don't like the version i remembered is
like not the version i watch like it was
so funny i thought i did a great job i
was like really really proud of myself
so now i'm in the head space where i'm
like oh my god like i killed it like for
a first show you know everyone tells you
after like my agents are like that was
great but like what are they gonna say
you know they're winning that was bad
yeah what is margo going to say you
stunk
so you know what she might she might but
so like you never really know but so i
was really glad that i taped it and now
i'm i have another one on monday i'm
thinking maybe i'll do one more in new
york like the more practice the better
yeah um but i'm like that first show for
me there was three major humps have i
said this philosophy yet on the toast i
think so three major humps of life of
tour oh yes no so far there's only been
two okay so the people and
and the second is the first show the
second was writing the material
like coming up with it and the third was
doing the show and now i've done all
three and you don't understand the
weight that has been lifted off my chest
i'm a new woman
hear me
we love it we love this new woman energy
so thanks everyone for coming out last
night thanks for putting up with me on
the podcast i promise i'll stop talking
about it now and we've got a great show
for you guys today we do i think we need
to get into everything there's so many
like news stories that require our take
fullest attention so without further a
do do do it is time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
now today's episode is brought to you by
the one and only sports society jackie
can you do a little qvc action for us i
would love to so spritz society is a
canned wine cocktail that jackie i ben
our whole family have launched a couple
months ago and we know you guys have
been loving it we wanted to thank you
guys so much they are canned wine
cocktails that come in four flavors
sparkling wine they have natural flavors
they're best enjoyed chilled they're so
good they're the best thing i drink now
like i plan on drinking a ton tonight i
can't drink um heart seltzers anymore
unfortunately because the malt plays
with my belly and i know a lot of people
have problems with malt and so spritz is
just a better alternative in my opinion
wine based delicious flavors pineapple
grapefruit lemonade
blood orange which is most you know
similar to a traditional spritz they're
so good they're so light they're a great
gift if you're going to someone's house
this weekend and we've got a great offer
because i know a lot of you guys have
joined our subscription program which is
great so you're never like running out
of wine um and as a thank you
we're so excited to welcome you guys for
all the support from spritz we're gonna
offer you a sickening
offer you can subscribe for three months
and pay for two so essentially you get
an entire month of wine free so as a
sports society subscriber you get early
access to merge drops special events and
offers from spritz society and you'll be
rdh if you miss out on this subscription
sign up for a subscription today and for
three months for the you'll get three
months for the price of two and that's
only when you go to spritsociety.com
toastvip that's spritsociety.com
toastvip join the subscription
get three months pay for two so
essentially you're getting an entire
month of wine for free which is just a
fabulous offer
fabulous offer fabulous camera work that
is thank you for your work that's what
we call teamwork teamwork makes the
dream work it does okay our first story
page six is reporting out of nowhere
sort of the kim kardashian and p
davidson are officially dating yeah like
i don't know pete asked her to be his
girlfriend and page six had you know
spyware in the room i don't understand
what this where this article's coming
well everyone's been referencing these
set of photos i watched the video there
like at a grocery store they're at some
like shopping center they get out of the
car they hold hands for a millisecond to
like walk towards the store and then
they let go of each other's hands okay
but is that the officiality no no no
this article like is separate from that
where page six has exclusively learned
that kim and pete are dating the news of
their romance like comes from a source
who is telling page six that they're
officially dating i just don't like we
seen them on dates like we knew that
they were dating everyone's like posting
this as if like
pete asked kim publicly to the
girlfriend yeah like i'm just what do
you mean you're telling me why is this
different why is this different from
what we've seen them on dates yeah and
honestly if there's kardashian related
news and it doesn't come from tmz like
i'm looking at it with like a little
really yeah but then i did see the
picture of them holding hands like at
the grocery store parking lot but you
know what's so crazy there's thousands
of pictures of them holding hands at the
grocery store when you watch the video
they hold hands for a millisecond like
how long a second
just like they get out of the car they
hold hands and they drop hands they get
out of the car they come around the
sides they hold hands does he get the
door for her no and then they drop hands
okay but like the amount of pictures you
can take in one second yeah
well i mean it was really cute and
okay so they're dating
so they're dating
it's so weird to me like i can't get
over it
i'm i'm
i'm gonna go along for the ride because
i'm really i am here for it i'm just
like so confused yeah i feel that you
know yeah but i think kim's having
probably a great time and that's all we
want for her keith's having a great time
amazing so i'm having a good time why
wouldn't i have a good time no and you
know i feel like kim has a lot going on
with the kids and all of her businesses
and the fact that she's with someone who
has to be in new york for like a couple
days a week is actually probably kind of
nice oh for sure i mean well i mean she
was literally with someone who had to be
in wyoming for 365 days a year but
that's extreme but kim's not the type of
girl like courtney and travis are
together all the time because like
courtney like runs poosh and has lots of
free time to invest in her children her
family her relationship and kim it's
like she's a million businesses has to
prioritize the kids so it's nice to have
a boyfriend who also has other things
going on thing other thing going on
yesterday
he's busy
he's busy yeah i'm sure he'll be busier
now yeah gotta make time yeah so they're
dating and i'm
i'm so
i like
i'm so happy for you know you know i'm
so happy
i'm just so confused i am too like it
was the rollout has been confused it was
less confusing when they were being so
low-key about it i agree but now with
the flavor flav and these
paparazzi pics like we know
a celebrity if they want to go get
coffee privately like they can do it
it can be most not all
most paparazzi pictures the person is
aware that they're being photographed or
they're and their team may be set up her
own paparazzi yes i actually learned
that a few years ago was crazy i went to
a charity gala where kim was being
honored for the gift of life bone marrow
registry if you're not in the registry
you should be and
she came with her own paparazzi and i
was like i was leaving and she was
living at the same time this guy was
taking pictures of her and then the guy
taking pictures of her gets in her car
and i'm like
what
and i'm like oh it's her own personal
paparazzi so she can get her own photos
which i actually really respect yeah no
it's and they're always premium premium
so um but these didn't look like her you
know
payroll
photographer it looked like a true like
paparazzi in the wild like splash news
yeah got it
okay so we'll we're we're off to the
races you guys what if like they get
married they won't no i know but like
let's just play a game what if beautiful
yeah
beautiful
what's the age difference how old is
pete pete just turned 28 kim is 41.
love it
i'm so biased when it comes to age
differences like of course well i mean
what do you mean because if it was a
female who was 28 and well that's a
whole other conversation but like even
like okay i think a similar age gap is
probably like harry styles and olivia
wilde
loathe entire life okay but i feel like
that's
that bias is fine because at least
you're not just doing it based on the
gender
no no but you know i would be lying if i
said like it's definitely different no
but now these days we're coming down
harder on the older men who are going
for the younger we should like she's 41
he's 28 jake gyllenhaal is 40 is his
girlfriend's 25 that's really not so
different yeah no i know it's
unacceptable completely unacceptable no
i'm all for equality except on the
subject the tables are turning i think
it's i think it's different like and i
really
i like to believe i'm like a real
card-carrying feminist but it's
different no but i think that that's
what you're being is what i'm saying no
because if we're feminists like we're
supposed to be equal and then it's wrong
for both people because we're equal oh
right
yeah technically so i don't know what
the right thing is but i definitely feel
weird if a 40 year old man takes a 25
year old girl i think that's weird and
problematic if a 40 year old woman did a
25 year old guy i'm like get your life
25 is actually just at 40 women 25
actually yes i agree sorry there's a
certain age where like you're still
really considered young i think that's
25 and below yeah 25 included and below
yes because the brain is still fully
forming and maybe some people need a few
extra days on the fully formed brain i
agree yeah but i'm 26 you're in business
yeah i don't think kim is like taking
advantage of pete no no no i just would
be lying if i didn't say like
women can date younger men but i don't
think men should date younger women like
much younger
and that's what i said okay and that's
that's probably it just feels different
to me and i'm sorry i feel like i need
to be honest with our listeners i think
you know what for me it really just
depends on the people and whether or not
i like them
and i'm going to be honest about that
and every time it's going to be
different a hundred percent i don't have
any like hard and fast rules like i'm
just going to evaluate the two of you
based on like the feelings you give me
100 100
100
okay are you ready for our next story
it's it's some sad couple news i mean
this is i know break up the season we
have two big breakups today first kaia
gerber and jacob allordy break up after
one year of dating which is so shocking
to me i know because they were just like
always giving us the most sickening
moments and one because they're so
low-key and couples like that usually
for me i've found
are like founded in real like they have
a good foundation of a relationship and
they usually last longer and two like
when you're both that like gorgeous like
what do you even have to fight about i
know seriously like no i i can't fathom
i'm shocked like for real i i'm saddened
no me too this was like a premium a-list
low-key gorgeous fashion couple like i
loved everything about it and the very
few like red carpet moments we got from
them were so sick i think we literally
have one from like the lacma event no
but like even these pictures of them
like walking down the street yeah like
for the mecca after party this one at
them at the gala in september like that
was the best the most iconic like i
can't believe that more people aren't
like referencing this photo yeah it
should be in history books i agree the
thing is is now that i've kind of
gotten to know jacob allordy for a
little while i led to believe he's the
toxic one
that's just a feeling that i have like i
think and i don't know this for proof i
just it's a vibe i got from the movies i
feel like he was really mean to joey
king after they broke up
and i could just see him being toxic
that's just my opinion okay based on no
facts
i don't see that but i also not like as
in it as you are i just feel like maybe
sometimes when you're so perfect and
you're so good like the two of you maybe
things get a little boring
you know yeah because when you're so
when you're a little you know
like us you got to be funny no you have
to make up for it a million times like
you have to be the funniest person the
smartest person the greatest person
embarrassing things that happen that
bond you to your partner but when you're
just shutting down when the whole world
is a catwalk and you're just a
supermodel like where are the funny like
laughable moments but is that
closed-minded of us to assume that just
because you're beautiful you don't have
like quirks but like you don't like like
is this biased of us i can't tell it's i
mean trust me i'd rather be absolutely
gorgeous with nothing going on than like
what i am now but
agreed obviously i think that makes it
okay obviously we're really questioning
like our double standards no this is a
double standard for sure like it's not
nice to say like models have nothing
going on but like they don't okay i'm
kidding i'm totally kidding but no i
hear you like when you're so beautiful
like life is so easy for you and like
you're famous your parents are famous
you're rich your parents are rich what
could go wrong yeah i'm just curious i
might be wrong tell me what could go
wrong in the life of kaya gerber i don't
know actually that's like a bad omen to
wish on someone that's not what i'm
saying no but it's i just don't
understand how you and your perfect
boyfriend can break up like we talk a
lot about how you need adversity in life
and i think it must be hard for her to
to find adversity yeah maybe that's her
adversity
a lack of adversity
breakup maybe
maybe this is it yeah wishing her the
best yeah wishing both of them the best
i mean i'm like i just but you know
what's exciting is like these are two
fabulous gorgeous a-list people who are
now back on the market and that's like
fun for us you know so we're talking kya
gerber shawn mendes
love that
jacob lordy camilla come on
i don't see it okay
that's cute okay you're right there's a
lot of like young hollywood
singles now out and about it it'll make
things interesting at least for the
morning toast and i do think like i mean
everything in hot like they say like it
comes in threes but i do think if you're
in a hollywood couple and like you saw
that jacob allordy is now single you
might get out of here like questioning
your situation
you know when it rains it pours and now
maybe the floodgates are open or like
maybe kaya saw sean was finally back on
the market and she decided to drop jacob
like the nobody that he is
and get over to shawn mendes camp you
never know you never know you never know
what goes through the mind of a young
hot person you know
no i i really i will never know
okay our next story another couple that
is called it quits katherine dennis and
her boyfriend caleb ravenel have
reportedly broken up wow
source told us weekly she broke up with
him and they are no longer living
together there is no bad ill will
between them i feel like four out of
four couples this week there's no bad
ill will between them well who do you
believe
i actually really do believe that
camilla and sean like are still friends
like i do believe that
yeah i don't know if i believe that kai
and jacob are gonna like love each other
like i didn't no i don't i don't think
they even said that and i don't think
bachelor and her husband are gonna be on
good terms no i i yeah what's the point
then stay married yeah right yeah uh the
source shared that catherine wants to
get married and have more kids and caleb
apparently wasn't on board
catherine as we know currently shares
two
uh children with her ex thomas ravenel
and the fact that she was dating someone
who was also a ravenel was the craziest
thing to ever happen to the face of the
earth yeah i actually i mean we didn't
get to see that much of their
relationship or any of it maybe on the
show maybe just at the reunion they
talked about it but like i followed her
on instagram and it seemed like they had
such a great cute relationship and
they've been together for a long time
now so southern charm has been off for a
while i know but they're filming now
okay and i think it's gonna be good and
like naomi goes down and sorry naomi's
uh sorry naomi is like filming oh is she
yeah she's some of her instagram stories
have like she was at like a dog wedding
for like craig jr and stupid i know but
i'm so glad and paige has gone down
that's what i mean yeah and i actually
think paige and naomi are like cool i i
would imagine that they are i don't
think that naomi like wants to get back
together with me so
why not all move forward yeah
cute yeah cute but i'm sorry for
catherine i'm sorry for catherine too i
thought this was it for her do you ever
feel like catherine and chap were like
otp
no i feel like shep always liked
catherine everybody always liked
catherine i also felt that way about
craig
no i feel like you really like
protected her as a friend like in a real
platonic way obviously whitney has like
always been head over heels and love no
every single like the show if the early
seasons all
revolve around the fact that every man
was in love with katherine yeah and they
were all so mean and they couldn't deal
with the choice that she made yeah
i i feel that yeah it was a bizarre
choice it was but then she also
got pregnant so soon that like the
choice was made yeah you know there was
no like that was such a crazy time it
was such a crazy time it's honestly such
a good show yeah
i'm excited for it to come back me too
and now with like the page of it all
she's just a star and i can't wait to
see her in south carolina yeah i was
looking at the sewing down south
instagram and of course craig and paige
are really like
posting and they're out of bearing and
like she's been on the instagram like
with the pillows and stuff it's really
cute top that is so cute yeah she's such
a good like fashion girly like she could
sell those pillows a hundred people
should go on qvc with him
so but maybe not mix like business with
pleasure yeah so talking good to have
the two things separate so toxic unless
it's maybe society okay but maybe she
could like come out with a collection
yeah like a capsule page x so she knows
that she 100 should because she has like
a very distinct taste and actually was
watching her instagram yesterday she did
a whole q a about like her interior home
decor perfect plug for sewing down south
x page to sorbo free idea you guys free
idea
next up a little more breakup news
breakup update that's making things very
real for me lala kent changes her rand
tattoo to brand new after her breakup
with randall so this is to me like the
most concrete proof that they are
fully done because i wasn't totally sold
like i felt like she had to
punish him and stay away but i thought
maybe they would get back together but
she had a tattoo on her arm that says
rand and now it says brand new do you
think when she got the tattoo because
she's not a dumb person like she and she
said a million times that she knows like
how you get them is how you lose them
and she's really kind of club to
everything do you think when she got
this tattoo she had the idea already
like if anything happens i'll make it
brand new because she could have done
randall you know yes i think that this
is a girl who's got plans who knows the
only thing that makes me feel like maybe
not is that the r is capital
oh so it's brand new but the b is
lowercase um so it looks a little funny
and maybe she would have done a
lowercase r if she really like
oh yeah no by the way you just totally
debunked my whole theory like no you're
right
that's bizarre yeah yeah so it's just
like a little bit of um
improper grammar yeah but it's not like
a huge tattoo i've seen some terrible
cover-ups and as it comes as it pertains
to vanderpump rules like jack's getting
shotsy's name like this is nothing no
when it pertains to like just tattoos in
general she got like a little one she
has a little plan for it and she has
other tattoos so it's not the biggest
deal and you know what they'll always be
in each other's lives since they share a
child together so is it so bad you know
you have the father of your beloved
daughter on your arm no no but
now but it's officially over i'm eyes
wide open now i'm sorry i know how hard
this is for you
i just can't believe it i know but like
you can
i have to yeah like and lala can believe
it like she said a million times like
she's always been very
wary of
his past you know perhaps their future
and my love for rand like it's just an
extension of my love for lala yeah i
need to take it back yeah bring it back
to in the basket it belongs in it's just
it's obviously just a sad situation
because they have a child together
yeah
and like
and because they were cute and like she
was just like living living the best
life i hope she can like stay in that
house it's so nice yeah it is
it also is like
annoying to watch it because i'm so team
lala and like now when we're watching
her question other people's like
relationships like sheena's man's motive
and then it's like six months later like
her man she's gonna have to like answer
for that at the reunion
yes but like
she's doing everything she's she's
walking the wall she's walking the walk
she's doing exactly what she's asking
sheena to do yeah just to be smart i
actually think that she's very
principled and it all lines up right
that's true like if she had stayed like
then she really would have had a lot to
answer for yeah yeah exactly no they're
this man
i'm like obsessed with theo
[Music]
he just looks so young and fresh you
know he's so cute and sprightly so cute
and spritly sorry i know if you're
watching on the podcast you can't see
the gorgeousness that is the uh you're
missing out what a shame maybe what a
shame are you ready for our fifth and
final story that was fast
yeah also it's just like another bravo
story but they're all from different
shows so i don't feel bad
it's the final story
[Music]
beautiful
okay our fifth and final story jen
shaw's fraud case will be explored in a
new hulu documentary yes i saw the real
house of salt lake city star gen shaw's
legal scandal will be the subject of a
new hulu documentary called the
housewife and the shaw shocker
not a good name zero out of five on the
name
negative 11 out of five abc news's film
will center on shaw's march arrest and
accusation that she ripped off hundreds
of people in a nationwide telemarketing
scam that targeted the elderly shaw and
her assistant stewart smith's face
charges of conspiracy conspiracy to
commit wire fraud and conspiracy to
commit money laundering to which they
have pleaded not guilty as they await
trial in march 2022.
okay coming up the documentary will
explore the allegations as well as the
lavish lifestyle that shaw has
portrayed on the show it will include
interviews from her childhood classmate
her aunt and real housewives and her
aunt yes
who's in the hospital and maybe she has
more than one aunt okay and real
housewives of beverly hills alum dana
wilkie nobody asked for her she also
appeared on the house i've been the
hustler and i think that
it's she has no so my problem with
housewife in the hustler was that it was
like such a serious topic and i felt
like 75 of it like they really covered
it in a serious way but then they had
like danielle staub and dana wilkie who
like have no are not germane to the
topic no and they just add a level of
like
jovial is that the right word yeah wow
like they make it not serious yeah and
so i felt like the trailer for this one
was even like 10x on the not serious
even stupider when the crimes jen
committed herself like are so heinous
yes but also two alleged victims of gens
will share their stories about how they
were scammed by her trickery and that i
think will be extremely
telling telling and powerful yeah
because
we haven't heard like right now it's
they're just like all these faceless
vulnerable elderly people and like
there's so many of them whereas like
with tom gerardi like
we knew the specifics like even before
we watched housewife and the hustler
like we knew it was like victims of a
plane crash like okay and we knew that
the other people would come forward over
the years so
hearing from these victims i think is
going to be really powerful because
right now it's kind of abstract yeah i
agree i'm just hoping that they take it
like serious because the trailer was
giving comedy and it's like there's
nothing funny about it the trailer was
giving like you know
just silliness jovial vibes jovial vine
brian moylan is in it who writes the um
real housewives recaps and pump rules
recaps for vulture right
yes and he's just great so that's like
the perfect type of person who should be
in it like an actual housewives expert
yes and my only question about brian
moylan is he off uh co-wrote erica's
book with her yes
and i haven't looked into it why wasn't
he in the housewife and the hustler
where does he stand on all of that oh
that's a good call yeah also but i
haven't like looked at his twitter or
read
maybe he's addressed it but
that's just my question oh my god i
forgot about that
yeah i mean what i remember he wrote a
book you know the most recent housewives
book that like all the housewives
endorsed was
the guy who the editor-in-chief of
people magazine oh is that who dave
quinn right yeah he was people magazine
but right before that brian moylan had
written like
that book the history of the house the
history of the housewives and like he's
not called that but yeah i forgot what
it was called but he like tweeted that
like bravo likes like
like
sanctioned is that the right word
opposite of sanctioned what's up word
unsanctioned unsanctioned his book like
what like no one was allowed to
acknowledge it because like they like
stole his idea and yeah did it
on andy's that book that dave quinn
wrote was on andy's
publishing he is like a new publishing
company that was the first book they
released yeah so brian morland's just
like full of tea i could do a whole
documentary on brian morland yeah but
first i just want to know like his
thoughts on america's situation that's
actually a really good point and then
forgot to be in the gen cha documentary
when it's like you should be in the
erica one yeah you wrote her book you
spent so much time with her right you
got paid from her by her no but like you
sh they were he had to you know shadow
her for so long and like hear all of her
stories and everything maybe he signed
an nda when he wrote the book i would
actually bet that he did
perhaps and that's why he couldn't
participate because if he's in the shaw
one he obviously knows the people who
made the house within the hustler yeah
also just like the name like house
wrestler like i just thought was like a
bad name for you no i thought i actually
thought it was great no it was just too
like you know silly like
home like lifetime movie vibe
and so to double down on that for jen
shaw like no no i think the name is so
bad so bad but yes i will um definitely
be watching yes me too and i think it
will be good for everyone to have a
better understanding of the crime she's
being accused that's what happened with
erica like we were so clear on the
crimes and the 20 million dollars e.j
global like it really
um
organized everything very well for us
yes and it is coming out on november
29th on soon so we will have a full
picture like by the time we hit reunion
and that and it will help in holding her
accountable yeah because people can't
just you know say this this is too
confusing i don't understand right or
like jen explains it away like we have
proof now right
all right well that would be interesting
those were good stories thank you for
sharing you're so welcome i'm so glad
we're all caught up to speed i feel like
we can all head into the weekend you
know knowing that we know the fast life
stories that we need to know
and other than that i finished my book
last night rock paper scissors by alice
feeny it was a
thriller and it was really kind of crazy
like the whole book is really a slow
burn and then like the twist or the
explanation payoff etc was a pretty big
one that i did not see coming and if
you're into
no
[Laughter]
checking um please be nice
me you'd be nice i said well you don't
have to say if you have nothing nice to
say what was wrong with that i was happy
for you you got your twist i'm listening
well
um
if you're into like the thriller
lifestyle and you have patience i would
recommend it i rated it a four but so
many people message me they're like so
curious to hear your thoughts on this
book i couldn't even finish it so it's
not for everyone you have to be a
patient reader it was like spooky scary
skeletons with shivers down your spine
but i never felt like it was too
anxiety-inducing wow
okay actually it sounds pretty good yeah
i don't think you have the patience for
it i wouldn't thank you i would not
recommend it to you i'm so
impatient when it comes to books like
when it comes to life tv even with books
like my attention span is so short and
it's the sort of book i don't know if
this is spoils anything i don't think it
does but like once you find out the
ending it actually makes you want to
start the book again from the beginning
and like see all the signs and like it's
a whole nother book that's like shutter
island when you know the ending and then
you re-watch it like knowing the ending
you're like oh this is so obvious no or
it's just a whole different movie yeah
yeah um okay cool i haven't read in like
six months and actually no i just read
uh the good sister
on the plane so good and um sally
hackworth has a new book younger wife
but it doesn't come out till next year i
got us advanced copies will you share
with me yeah i got you one too sick i
know but it's like a book and it's like
i don't read these anymore like i just
read the kindle no i would do it i i
will take a book on vacation like i
can't read a book in my house it feels
so unnatural yeah and then like if you
want to read while your partner is
sleeping yeah good luck yeah that's true
actually last night i was tossing and
turning i told you i'm addicted to my
melatonin gummies and i tried to get off
of them last night
and i was like i should read
but i just watched watch tick tock you
should have read i know i know i would
have put you but i'm not in a book like
i didn't want to start a new one yeah i
mean it's so hard to start a new book
and i don't even have anything on my
list i don't know where i'm going from
here the next thing on my list i have
like three books on my list like i will
read like um beach read but it's like
it's not like life changing i'll read it
like when i'm bored on a beach you know
yeah um so i don't have
like
i had a bunch on my list and i read them
yeah okay i'll see if i can muster up
anything for you does it bother you so
much when you like have unread books
like in your goodreads like i just they
stare at me but i didn't want to finish
them i only have like two and i feel
good about my decision oh i have so
[ __ ] many ready that you just are
dnfing
yeah like what okay malibu rising oh i
didn't think it was good sorry okay
um where would it be in my thing
i don't know i feel like it would be in
like currently reading
yeah okay
malibu rising oh where the grass is
green and the girls are pretty that's
one of my that's one of two of my dnf's
did not like it we were liars
was recommended to me on tick tock and i
swear to god it was not in english i
couldn't understand i'm like am i stupid
i was there was so many characters
introduced on the first page i was like
how am i supposed to it was just
confusing me and giving me anxiety never
i never gave into that one oh and i
guess that's it even though i remember i
didn't finish um
the last mrs parish i remember you
didn't finish that hated
but it's not showing up on my list i
think that you bought that when you were
still on my kindle account so maybe i
should read it oh you know you're right
all my dnrs are on your kindle account
because i was like nervous to make my
own yeah but also like if it was
something that i had already read then
you don't have to feel bad about not
finishing it oh that's true
good times when we were in the same
channel that was fun then you can see
each other's kindle highlights and
that's just embarrassing yeah even
though i like never highlight anything
anymore i like i i i like highlighting
stuff but i never look at my highlights
but i do think like you know the once a
year when i do it's a treasure trove of
interesting information i mean my my
like most recent books is literally like
erotica it happened one summer
fix her up which is the first in the hot
and hammered stitch
um hot and hot and then i read love her
loser the second in the hot and hammered
series i'm dying wait can i see your
reads yeah
lots of um tessa bailey
okay why is eliza started oh you just
realized this is a rumor i talked about
on the podcast so good
wow all of your covers are like so fun
you know i don't read dark [ __ ] they're
all like animated like they're so cute
cute
except colleen hoover but i've pretty
much read all the colleen hoovers
yeah this is pretty good yeah i think
i'm like a really good mix of
like if you would like to read like
lightly like not get so
serious and dark my goodreads is a good
place to be like but you also don't only
like you've read some
moderately serious books i would say do
you consider colleen hoover seriously no
but i would consider um
the good sister like not not serious
yeah i guess yeah that's true
yeah i mean i guess the weirdest book i
ever read was nothing to see here but
that's a serious book yeah i know that's
what i just said yeah you said it's so
good
same thing yeah so good so good and
verity is a serious book i guess like
dark
twisted
my you're just like a book snob like no
i'm really not but my recently my read
list is so all over the place like
who is this woman you know like you have
no
like if you look at my goodreads like
you know what type of thing i'm genre
fluid that's so cool of you yeah no and
i'm just open to suggestions yeah
so hit me up i've been seeing people
have been sending me some suggestions i
need to take stock of them
and
find a new path forge a new path if you
guys like know my vibe like colleen
hoover tessa bailey but like i could
also go a little bit more seriously i
love devlin hugo send me some wrecks
okay all right that's our show you guys
that is our show we will see you on
monday i hope everyone has an amazing
amazing weekend you guys we did it we
deserve it it's not going to be as
amazing as ours because he's in town
that is true sorry sorry to like rub it
in your face sorry to this man thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heart radio cast box all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcast find us the morning chosen leave
a five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing day and if you made it
to the end of this episode why don't you
go drop an emoji on our most recent
instagram
what about a book wreck for the weekend
yes instead of that if you have a
tailored wreck for jackie or for me drop
it in our comments we would love to hear
from you we would love that thanks guys
have a great day and we'll see you
tomorrow
monday she means oh yeah bye